j'ai écouté aujourd'hui on va se
divertir un petit peu le cul en juin 16h
tous assez vulgaire d'entrée de jeu
heather qui veut dire l'un ou l'autre en
fait on va faire des choix aujourd'hui
entre deux propositions à chaque fois
c'est ce qu'on peut finalement quand on
s'ennuie avec des amis un excuse préféré
ça ou faire ça ah bah je préférerais
saab à moi ou pas du tout du tout voilà
c'était une très belle reconstitution
ces partis est ce que vous préférez
avoir toujours chaud ou avoir toujours
froid ça dépend si on peut faire quelque
chose ou pas parce que si on a froid on
met plein de vêtements et on a plus
froid alors je mets ça et revoit ensuite
combien de jeux avaient villa ou l'autre
et je fais partie et 59 % de gens
intelligents
c'est faux tu préfères lécher le sol en
boîte de nuit ou alors les chais la
cuvette des toilettes à moelle marc
bellemare tu sais comme intermarché
parce que là finalement lèche des
excréments mais ça se trouve dans le
club
quelqu'un marché dans des excréments
avant d'aller danser donc ça revient au
même mais peut-être que quelqu'un n'a
pas marché en des extrêmes ordre qu on
va dire lécher le sol d'un club aux 89 %
des gens avaient choisi salée est-ce que
tu préfère manger des haricots pour le
restant de ta vie ou être autorisés à
manger ton plat préféré
mais seulement trois fois par semaine
manger trois fois par semaine c'est
choquant même après moi j'ai encore de
l'âge donc c'est parti je résisterai
préfères-tu avoir une poche girafe ou
avoir une poche éléphants dans nos
moeurs à la girafe on préfère la girafe
bah oui et j'espère que les gens aussi
ah non les gens sont plutôt éléphants on
apprend des choses avant d'aller à
l'école au travail chaque jour préfère
et tu prendre un petit déjeuner
constitué de bonbons ou prendre un petit
déjeuner constitué de dell de poule et
pimentée par les ailes de poulet les
ailes de poulet en plus fini avec le
diabète ce qu'ils mangent des dragibus
tous les jours au petit déj c'est
n'importe quoi préfères-tu ne pas
préférer ne pas être capable d'arrêter
d'être sérieux ou ne pas être capable
d'arrêter de blaguer bas ne pas être
capable d'arrêter de blaguer et le rire
c'est la vie sans les connaître il ya
entendu une préférée de sérieux athoise
abuser ok ok les gens pensent pas comme
moi je les accepte
j'accepte préfères-tu être l'élève qui
dort tout le temps en cours ou est
l'élève qui parle tout le temps au cours
moi je faisais les deux j'avoue chose 2
mais honnêtement quitte à choisir mieux
vaut dormir voilà comme ça tu rattrape
t8 guy cage et tu fais pas chier le prof
quoi les gens ont choisi de parler
d'accord à temps c'est trop marrant de
découvrir les choix des autres des fois
t'es hyper étonné dans les prépas
l'air est de penser voilà florent pagny
moi si tu veux leur est ce que tu
préférais avoir ton cerveau transplanté
dans un robot ou avoir ton cerveau
transplantés donc dans quelqu'un du sexe
opposé dans une femme à l'égard météo
france tous pareils dans une fable
médiatement des gens choisissent à olé
de pervers préféré tuer avoir des
ongles longs de cinq pouces ou alors
constamment avoir un tube à dota bush
franchement les ongles comme ça j'ai un
petit côté wolverine au la majorité rêve
d'être wolverine
ça ne donne pas le faire et tu m que des
jeans ou mettre que des shorts des
shorts le plus confort a les jambes et
dj attend le short est super bien le
petit technique quand tu prends l'avion
le train mais toi en short c'est la
liberté de pensée feu en maniant si tu
n'avais pas le choix est ce que tu
préfères et te tuer ou faire rentrer et
on canet dans la guitare higuain
allez-vous cadel evans et fonce tu vas
aller défoncer c'est horrible sur godard
a tellement david o
évidemment tous pourris est-ce que tu
préférais être riche ou être célèbre or
préfères-tu vivent dans le passé ou le
futur
franchement vivent maintenant je veux y
aller dans le passé et dans le futur où
on va dire dans le futur mais si
j'arrive je me fais à tout le monde doit
y avoir dans le futur préférerais tu ne
pas être capable de faire des
compléments ou ne pas être capable de se
plaindre à intéressant soit qu un truc
va pas tu peux rien dire mais par contre
il me faire plaisir aux gens en disant
qu' ils sont beaux gentils soit tu peux
pas dire aux gens qu'ils sont beaux et
gentils et dès qu'un truc va pas tu le
dit et tu te plains en gros tu arrives
dpr franchement de pas de jeu pas être
capable de splendides bio bah voilà à
80% des humains sont des gens bien c'est
faux préfère es-tu apprendre l'histoire
ou apprendre les maths a révélé mats et
c'est toi les jeux vidéo est tous un peu
grâce aux pattes quand même un tout ça
là le bon virtuel mais l'histoire c'est
hyper important à le dilemme de foule
histoire et je suivais mes cours comme
axe haulotte a dû à plus de gens
préfèrent l'histoire mais c'est trop
important l'histoire savoir ce qui vous
est arrivé dans le passé ne jamais
l'oublier préfères-tu à être emporté par
un ouragan ou être perdu dans une
inondation anorak ans un peu violent à
bord à gauche - ses chances de survie
elles sont de - 10% on va dire
l'inondation attend les gens préfèrent
est emporté par un ouragan a amerri
puisque la fameuse chanson de scorpions
et que je choisirais tu entres avoir un
vous avez un cache oeil ou alors avoir
une jambe de bois alors déjà dans ces
deux cas humains poste est un pirate et
ça ça me plaît pas du tout me va très
bien en jambe de bois comme ça par âge
peut casser des coups tu as les gens
préfèrent 1 1 1 1 1 n'a jamais pu parler
dans un monde imaginaire à choisir étude
est une fée qui ne peut pas voler ou 1 1
qui dit m moi je voulais être le nom de
10 mètres et j'écrase la fille qui peut
pas voler beau match j'aurai les écraser
55% et jean hockey que choisirais-tu
entre manger ta nourriture favorite
jusqu'à la fin de tes jours ou alors moi
j'ai tout ce que tu veux mais ne jamais
prendre de poids bah franchement manger
ma nourriture favorite jusqu'à la fin de
ma vie je prends déjà pas de poids et je
peux pas en prendre mon corps est pas
normal la définition du corps de lâche
donc non je suis partie des neuf
pour cent des jours or je suis unique
personne et comme moi je ferais tu être
un chanteur excellent ou alors un
superbe écrivain à un superbe équilibre
pour le bat déjà puisqu'on est mal
partie vu comme je chante mal
aujourd'hui de créer des histoires est
tous assez poussée plus cool je trouve
moi les gens préfèrent chanter choisir
est une ville seul sur une île tropicale
ou alors de lits de vivre avec d'autres
gens en antarctique à vis seule je vais
mourir en deux heures donc vraiment
vivre avec d'autres gens préfèrent tu
avoir un iphone ou alors avoir un
téléphone qui utilisent android jouer
sur pc
voilà ça pour pas la question pourquoi
fait que je choisirais tu entres perdre
un bras et un pied ou perdre une jambe
et une main bras un pied tu choisirais
tu rentres vivre isolé ou affrontez ta
plus grande peur une fois par mois va
affronter ma plus grande peur une fois
par mois et qui fait ma vie avec des
gens être le meilleur chanteur du monde
mais est moche ou alors être le pire
chanteur du monde mais est beau et pas
franchement percer dans la musique en
étant hyper moche ce serait mon exploit
les gens préfèrent être beau
égoïste préféré tuer godzilla et
détruire du coup la moitié de la ville à
cause de ça mais tout le monde te
connaître à et moi je serai célèbre ou
tuer le kraken et sauver la ville des
futures catastrophes mais sans que
personne ne le sache non des browne on
n'a pas besoin de la célébrité on s'en
fout on veut sauver les gens est resté
dans l'ombre
allez 56% de faux culs est-ce que tu
préférais perdre ton pouce préféré ou
perdre l'index et le doigt d'honneur
notamment préféré bah alors qu'est-ce
qui de quoi on a besoin pour jouer bas
de l'index pour cliquer ou pour appuyer
sur la touche d pour se déplacer dans la
même eau le poussa à quoi quand on joue
à sauter dans les fesses bas le pouce
balle et s'est cabré vertueux entre être
un génie dans un monde de gens pas
intelligent ou être intelligent ou au
best way pas intelligent un bond de
génie puisqu'il vient de se passer pas
intelligent dans un monde de génie a
atteint 82% des gens préféraient des
génies dans un monde de gens pas
intelligent attendu c'est carrément
égoïste et abusait va faire et tu veux
manger une pomme de pain ou un gland pas
un gland un gland attention je trouve
une astuce à la boulangerie et
pâtisserie qui s'appelle le plan et
c'est un truc super bon dos car globe
c'est bien mieux qu'une pomme de pain
qui est la plus attirante jennifer
aniston angelina jolie or préféra tu
être les dernières humain on vit sur
terre ou alors être bon si je suis le
dernier rue main en vie sur terre comme
j'ai dit alors je vais survivre
vingt minutes avant de mourir donc je
vais être morts et laissé cette chance à
quelqu'un d'autre qui fera des trucs
bien le faire et tu manges et les
cartons pour un pied de cochon ou nager
dans une piscine de réformes et de vera
si on bouche
tous les trous de mon corps je veux bien
nager dans la piscine j'espère que 63%
des gens qui ont choisi cette
possibilité souhaite aussi se boucher
tous les records préféré tue tout
emporter des fringues que tu aimes et
que les autres détestent ou alors tout
le temps porter des fringues que tu
détestes mais que les autres on s'en
fout de ce que j'en pense fais toi
plaisir mais ce que tu aimes atteint 43%
de gens qui préfèrent suivre le
mouvement quand même et on apprend des
trucs de fou préfèrerais tu être un chat
ou être un chien être un de chats
et dormir 18 heures par jour avoir de la
bouffe illimité référé tu ne pas être
capable de t'asseoir ou ne pas être
capable de te lever
bah si tu es pas capable de t'asseoir au
bout d'un moment tu meurs de fatigue et
si je suis pas capable de me lever ces
barrages
j'appelle capote leur demande de prendre
ma chaise et de l'amener à un endroit
voilà ne pas capable de le voir alsa
préfères tu chantais tout ce que tu dis
ou alors on préfère danser tout est
mouvement et pas franchement envie comme
je chante mal chanter tout ce que je dis
comme ça les gens en auront marre de moi
à 3 bat à aller en prison pour cinq ans
ou regarder tous les épisodes de fut là
à regarder tous les épisodes quand même
il ya 12 % de menteur ou d'inconscient
préféré tu toi tu sens le caca ou alors
tu sens le cac à vous vous avez compris
voir tout est compliqué quitte à choisir
je préfère sentir bon mais sentir que
des odeurs de cas car quoique bon dans
les deux cas c'est invivable
dans un parc d'attractions ou dans un
seau dans un seau monga direct
d'accord attend vivre au milieu des
animaux et tout et s'en occuper c'est
génial
les gens préfèrent goudurix ou space
mountain préféré tu être chinois ou être
japonais être asiatiques aux eaux le
site afin d' écran bleu bout on a cassé
la matrice bogard oui belge ans devient
fin de cette vidéo sur heather pas si
vous a plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
aller mais comme d'habitude c'est bon il
faisait pas un site sur ça parce que
c'est vrai que des fois on se pose des
questions avec ses potes qui sont
complètement débile qui n'ont aucun sens
un peu comme la mea mais ça fait marrer
ça passe le temps des x men ça crée des
conflits
d'ailleurs j'espère qu'il n'a pas ouvert
des débats sans fin et n'ayant aucun
sens dans les commentaires écouter cette
chanson le fait plutôt bien savoir
garder c'est évident une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien et tient tout le monde
ah oui pis
oh